Schönheit liegt im Auge des Betrachters
von der lasse ich mich bei der heutigen
reaction nicht vom
das ist die schönste Frau der Welt und
zwar ganz office
Schönheit liegt ja eigentlich im Auge
des Betrachters
die ist alle die ist jetzt nicht genau
auch wenn vielleicht jeder ein leicht
unterschiedlichen Sinn von Schönheit hat
so gibt es trotzdem immer wieder
Misswahlen ja äh ich bin mit
meiner Wohnung
ich bin die schönste Frau in meiner
Wohnung und den Titel kann mir niemand
nehmen auch wohl niemanden trifft das so
sehr zu wie auf Jael shelbia obwohl sie
erst 21 Jahre alt ist gilt sie für viele
bereits als die schönste Frau der Welt
also das ist ähm
sie waren nicht nur auf Platz eins der
TC Chandler Liste in diesem Jahr sondern
ist schon seit ihrer jugendstammgast in
den top-rängen der Auswahl ja el
shabbiam ist quasi der FC Bayern der
schönheits-ranking ja und ich bin der
FCM
und der ist schlecht dieser Tag startet
für gewöhnlich immer genau hier in ihrem
neuen Apartment das über insgesamt vier
Zimmer verfügt und sich im obersten
Stock eines der größten Hochhäuser der
Stadt befindet die Penthousewohnung ist
zudem Moskau als erste eigene Wohnung
und wurde nicht nur von einem
Inneneinrichter gestaltet sondern
verfügt ihre Wohnung komplett egal wo wo
also bist du nicht nur sehr schön sie
weiß auch wie sehr Aussehen zu Geld
machen kann mit über einer Million
Followern auf
[Musik]
mal schauen ob sie antwortet und ob ich
dann überhaupt wieder antworten sollte
an einem typischen Morgen wacht ja elf
hier dann in ihrem großen Bett auf in
dem sie meistens übrigens alleine
schläft ja das können wir ganz schnell
ändern ja ey manchmal teilt sie ihr Bett
nämlich mit Enna ihrem und der für sie
wie ihr eigenes Kind ist der Husky ist
erst ein Jahr alt und für Jahr ein
wichtiger Bestandteil ihres Lebens
die ist wunderschön verdient ihr eigenes
Geld und hat einen Hund
ein anderer wichtiger Part in ihrem
Leben ist ihr Freund um mehr der
allerdings in einem anderen Land lebt
als die schöne 21-Jährige mit ihr daher
eine Fernbeziehung führen muss
ich ruf mal Nachrichten besser wieder
zurück nachdem ja l aufgestanden ist
macht sie zunächst eine kurze
Yoga-Einheit auf ihrem Balkon und Blick
dabei über die Stadt wo sie bereits
einen international erfolgreiches Model
ist lebt sie aber nicht in Paris London
oder New York sondern im Nahen Osten
eine Region die eigentlich gar nicht für
Mode oder so
ist israelen und da sie sehr
heimatverbunden ist will sie ihrem Land
treu bleiben aber das chillig
Israeliten oder israelische Frauen
generell
ich kann es jetzt nicht auf Männer
beziehen weil ich bin heterosexuell aber
die sind wirklich also das ja teilweise
auf Instagram gesehen die der also
Schweden ja okay aber
ja l achtet daher bei ihrem
morgendlichen Frühstück streng darauf
und das ist immer koscher ist aus diesem
Grund ist sie morgens meist ein paar
frische Früchte dazu ein Spiegelei sowie
ein Brot hey das ist genau mein
Frühstück
Brot mit Guacamole drauf Salz Pfeffer
Spiegelei und dazu so eine Porridge Bowl
da Hafermilch und bisschen so Früchten
drüber
also um mehr und jail with your
sometimes
nach dem Frühstück geht es für die
schönste Frau der Welt anschließend
meistens direkt ins Büro und das sich
auch nur ein paar Häuser weiter im
Geschäftsviertel von Tel Aviv befindet
wenn sie dort ankommt setzte sich
allerdings nicht an den Schrein sondern
trifft sich dort mit Fotografen oder
Designern und plant ihre Shootings aber
die ist jetzt nicht model
sondern macht nur Shootings oder oder
wie ist das jetzt genau dass sie nun
auch offiziell als schönste Frau der
Welt betitelt wurde reißen sich alle
möglichen Marken darum mit ihr zu
arbeiten
die Lippen werden ein bisschen zu viel
ne die sind aufgespritzt oder
verstehe nicht warum macht man das das
sind ja das ist ja also das ist ja
einfach dann hast du so ein Schlauchboot
immer ist gut wenn Teller lief dann
schiffbrüchig wird denkt ja elf liegt
einfach economy oder Business Class der
irrt sich die schönste Frau der Welt
fliegt nämlich Privatjets und zwar nicht
weil sie selber so viel Geld verdient
sondern weil ihr Freund um mehr als
einer der erfolgreichsten Musiker
Israels sich vor ein paar Jahren ein
eigenes Privatjet gekauft hat ein
eigenes Privatjet
heißt es nicht einen eigenen Privatjet
aber das wäre auch nichts für mich da
bin ich raus ich hasse so kleine
Flugzeuge wenn das alles wackelt nee ich
würde nie private das letzte schon
Podcast besprochen auf gar keinen Fall
in l.a lebt zudem auch ihr Freund um
mehr und mehr kalifornischen Metropole
hat ja Elm auch ihre größten Erfolge
gehabt okay etwa das Shooting für Kim
Kardashians Beauty Marke für dass sie
die Kardashians übrigens persönlich
angefragt haben aus diesem Grund hat ja
eben auch schon für Kylie jenners in
care Produkte gemodelt und soll privat
mit den beiden Megastars in Kontakt
stehen easy
ich finde es auch viel verrückter ist
eine Fernbeziehung mit einem Typen in LA
hat
Germany's the little bit Nira doch wenn
mal kein Shooting ansteht und ja ähm
nicht um die Welt jettet ist sie dennoch
recht aktiv in ihrem Alltag zu Hause so
widmet sie sich in ihrer Zeit abseits
der Modelaufträge vor allem ihrem Körper
denn wie sie mal in einem Interview
sagte ist ihr Körper und insbesondere
ihr Gesicht ihr ganzes Kapital
halt auch ein Ablaufdatum
irgendwann mit 35 oder so ist dann
kriege ich halt vorbei genauso wie bei
dem Fußballer
ihr guckt mich natürlich noch wenn ich
irgendwann 35 bin selbstverständlich
weil Humor
geht nicht kaputt
ihr guckt nicht noch mit 35
Tagen geht es daher in ihrer Heimat und
Tel Aviv vormittags immer erstmal zum
Trainieren ins Fitnessstudio dabei geht
sie jedoch nicht einfach in irgendein
Studio sondern nutzt ein Fitnessstudio
mit Geräten die speziell für weibliche
Models entwickelt wurde ist denn ihre
Freundin hier rechts
geht es nun am Mittag als nächstes
wieder nach Hause ich schwöre die sagen
jetzt so ja am Mittag geht es dann da
und dahin Bruder wenn das ihr Mittag ist
ne wann steht sie denn dann auf um 5 Uhr
oder was jetzt schon Yoga gemacht
gegessen war schon im Büro hatte schon
Shootings war schon beim Sport und jetzt
ist erst Mittag damit Sie immer genau
das richtige Essen kann bereitete sich
meistens schon am Wochenbeginn ihr Essen
vor zu Hause macht sie dieses Essen dann
einfach nur noch warm ein typisches
Gericht bei Yael besteht z.B aus
gegartem Brokkoli mit Blumenkohl und
Möhren
niemals Model sein ne also wenn man mich
anguckt denkt man natürlich ich wäre
Model aber mit dem Essen hier zwei so
Pantoffeln und dann so hier so
Blumenkohl wenn Sie im Ausland ist gibt
es oft gar nicht die Möglichkeit sich
koscher zu ernähren bei Shootings in
anderen Ländern kam es schon öfter dazu
dass ja eben sich tagelang nur von
einfachen Crackern ernähren musste um
nicht gegen die strikten Regeln ihrer
Religion zur verstoßen Germany's
possible jailf you wanna come we have
Plan Airport Germany am Nachmittag steht
für jahreläufig noch eine Arbeit an die
sie neben dem Modeln sehr
leidenschaftlich verfolgt sie ist
nämlich auch Schauspielerin ach so
spielt in der Nickelodeon-Serie Palmach
mit oh mein Gott ich dachte sie wäre
auch noch Bauern nebenbei
müssen wir mal ein bisschen so auf dem
Bauernhof dann helfe haben damit ohne
irgendwelche Schauspielerfahrung kam ja
elbton direkt ans Set und begann in der
Sendung mitzuwirken übrigens mit viel
Erfolg denn Palmach ist heutzutage die
beliebteste Jugendsendung in Israel
crazy
never heard of Hit butjail if you wanna
come play Germany we have Theater
Cologne Cinedom Kino
verbringt die offiziell schönste Frau
der Welt dann ganz anders als man das
wenn er strenggläubigen israelen
erwarten würde wenn sie einmal verriet
ist sie von all den Regeln in ihrem
Alltag oft auch mal etwas überfordert
und dass sie noch jung ist will sie auch
gerne einfach mal Spaß haben so liebt
sie es richtig extravagante Partys zu
feiern oder generell mit Freunden abends
in den Club zu gehen ihre Religion
erlaubte sie nämlich Alkohol zu trinken
und genau das macht sie auch sehr gerne
mal okay
ich trinke in Kölsch
Cologne Bier geil with friend of mine
selfie Sandra very zum Panic Person
liebte nicht nur Partys an sich sie ist
doch gerne Gastgeberin und macht Ihren
Geburtstag dabei immer zur ultimativen
Feier mit hunderten von Gästen und
pop-hüssen dekoriert Kirche teilweise
größer als die meisten Hochzeiten dabei
lässt sie auch gerne mal Kunstwerke und
Gemälde von sich selber aufstellen um
sich so wortwörtlich selbst zu feiern
ein über zwei Meter hohes Kunst Portrait
von Yael von sie so schön dass sie es
sich inzwischen sogar in ihre eigene
Wohnung hing doch was
ich dachte zu Beginn dieses Videos und
auch über die Dauer immer so ein
bisschen okay kommt aus Israel achtet
auf Religion auf Essen sagt auch Träger
ab wenn die Kleidung nicht koscher ist
Blabla aber
vielleicht doch ein bisschen
behalten wenn du willst und von daher
würde ich an der Stelle das heutige
Video jetzt auch beenden meine lieben
Freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lasst gern einen Daumen hoch unter dem
Video hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nichts verpassen schreibt mir gerne
unten in die Kommentare welche Person
wirklich nur aus äußerliche bezogen ne
wirklich für euch die schönste Person
der Welt ist
einfach Laserdrucker reinschreiben